I always found it interesting to think
about why there weren't any groups of
men that were trying to increase the
amount of men that were in nursing or
dental hygienists our education or an
education Social Work I always found
that interesting I was and then I their
lower paid the disciplines um and then
and then I recently started thinking
about this in terms of sports with the
NFL and NBA and I was like hmm
there are just less Asian people and
Latino people and white people there's
just there's more black people that are
just better athletes and are we going to
decrease the standards for people of
different
from a better Asian or Latino to morning
is funny that the the the discussion
about gender differences in occupational
position let's say is unbelievably
narrow you know it tends to focus on the
highest corporate positions that's not
all of it but it tends to focus on the
highest corporate positions or the
highest paid positions but certainly
it's quite interesting if you're if
you're into this sort of thing I suppose
to go online and just look up the Labor
Statistics from from the American
federal government because they they
rank order occupations by gender
you know proportion and what bricklayers
are that's that that's the occupation
that's the most gender skewed there's
like no female bricklayers and but no
one cares about that and it's kind of
interesting well no but it is
interesting because it's not like
bricklayers don't make a good living you
know like the skilled trades people make
a damn good living but heavy machinery
operators very few women there are two
so but the percentage of work-related
deaths ninety three percent well that's
a problem yeah I mean that there's a
bunch of reasons why men make more money
on average than women do and one of them
is that they're they're more willing to
work outside that's one they're more
willing to move that's another they work
longer hours and if you work 13% more
hours you make forty percent more money
on that that's the stat so so that the
effect of overtime is nonlinear 13% more
hours forty percent more income yeah Wow
yeah yeah well you can you I think
that's a good example of how you know
let's say you have a bunch of employees
and you're trying to differentiate them
for promotion like and let's say they're
all operating within a relatively narrow
band perhaps they aren't but let's say
for this example they are it's like well
the person who puts out 10% more
self-evidently so all this guy's around
like 10% more that would be what about
next year 45 minutes a day something
like that he goes the extra mile while
he's going to get the promotion and